Salut les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux !
Aujourd'hui, je vous parle d'un sujet
qui me colle à la peau :
le miel.
Mais attention, il y a miel et miel.
Il y a le vrai miel,
comme le miel de thym, de châtaignier,
d'acacia, de tilleul, de luzerne
et le faux miel.
Mais pas de panique, je vous donne toutes
les clés pour bien faire la différence
et profiter du bon miel
de nos apiculteurs et de ses vertus.
On va même aller à la rencontre d'un producteur
pour découvrir son travail.
Mais auparavant, on va butiner dans l'atelier.
Hmm ! On l'appelle
parfois le nectar des dieux.
Mais il n'y a pas que les dieux
qui aiment le miel, moi aussi.
Et vous aussi vous en raffolez.
Chaque année,
les Français en consomment 40000 tonnes
et la production française explose.
Plus 47% entre 2019 et 2020.
Il faut dire que le miel est réputé
pour ses propriétés antiseptiques
antibactériennes et antivirales.
Tiens à ce propos.
J'ai fait une vidéo sur ce sujet.
N'hésitez pas à la consulter.
Le lien se trouve ici.
Je le disais,
les Français aiment le miel, à tel point
que la demande dépasse l'offre.
En moyenne, on ne récolte en France
que 20% du miel que nous consommons.
Alors pour répondre à la demande,
eh bien on en importe.
D'Espagne, d'Ukraine, d'Asie ou encore d'Amérique du Sud.
Mais produire du miel de qualité,
ça ne s'improvise pas.
C'est tout un art, une technique, un savoir-faire.
Et forcément, ça coûte cher.
Du coup, certains n'hésitent pas à frauder
à couper leur miel, comme on dit
avec du sirop de sucre, par exemple.
Mais ça,
c'est du faux miel.
Ouh j'ai les abeilles là !
Je te comprends moi aussi.
On appelle ça une adultération.
C'est interdit par la loi.
En Europe,
la règle est très claire le miel doit être issu de la ruche,
sans ajout ou retrait de quoi que ce soit.
Or, selon une étude européenne, 30% du miel vendu n'est pas conforme aux normes.
Avec la truffe, le café, l'huile d'olive.
C'est même l'un des produits alimentaires les plus contrefaits au monde.
Alors, pour que vous sachiez bien de quoi il retourne quand on parle de vrai miel,
je vous propose d'aller faire un tour
chez un apiculteur pour découvrir comment on le produit.
On part tout de suite en Anjou au bord d'une petite rivière :
la Moine.
Oh le pot ! Tiens d'ailleurs,
n'oublie pas de m'en rapporter un.
Évidemment, tu sais très bien que jamais je ne t'oublie.
Allez, c'est parti !
Nous sommes au moulin de Beau Rivage, pas très loin de la ville de Cholet.
Ici, on produit du miel depuis plus d'un siècle
grâce aux abeilles. Seulement voilà, ce précieux insecte
est aujourd'hui en danger  depuis une quarantaine d'années.
La population d'abeilles en Europe
a diminué d'un tiers.
Plusieurs facteurs sont en cause.
L'utilisation de certains pesticides,
des parasites comme le varroa.
Il s'agit d'un acarien
qui se fixe sur les abeilles.
Le frelon asiatique et aussi
le manque de nourriture pour les abeilles
à cause des monocultures et également de la raréfaction des bandes fleuries
en certaines saisons autour des champs.
C'est en fait la combinaison
de plusieurs de ces facteurs
qui affaiblit les colonies.
Du coup, en 2021,
moins de 10000 tonnes de miel
ont été récoltées en France.
Jamais les chiffres n'avaient été aussi bas.
Les abeilles jouent pourtant un rôle essentiel
dans notre écosystème et notre alimentation.
Elles sont indispensables à l'agriculture. Sans abeilles,
une bonne partie des plantes à fleurs
ne peuvent pas se reproduire.
Et sans ces plantes à fleurs,
on peut dire adieu
à beaucoup de nos fruits et légumes.
Allez, assez parlé, allons récolter du miel !
Bonjour !
Bonjour ! Je vous présente
Jérôme, apiculteur.
Alors Jérôme,
on est au début du printemps.
Il y a beaucoup de fleurs autour de nous
et on le voit,
les abeilles ont commencé à sortir.
Il y en a qui reviennent chargées de pollen ou de nectar,
d'autres qui repartent.
L'activité a commencé.
Exactement ! Les abeilles
vont commencer à sortir,
à chercher du pollen et du nectar
pour faire leurs provisions
pour l'hiver prochain.
Une ruche comme celle-ci peut produire
quelle quantité de miel ?
Tout dépend de la météo en fait.
De la force de la colonie, de la météo.
S'il y a vraiment du beau temps
en même temps que les fleurs.
Mais une colonie peut faire de 15 kilos par an à 100 - 120 kilos, 150 kilos.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'elles ont fait ces abeilles pendant l'hiver ?
Donc elles sont restées
à l'intérieur de la ruche.
La reine a arrêté de pondre
fin novembre début décembre.
Elles ont consommé le miel
qu'elles ont ramassé
pendant la belle saison. Et du coup, là
elles vont attendre que le printemps arrive
et dès qu'il y aura les premiers pollens, la reine
va recommencer à pondre.
Et c'est reparti pour une nouvelle saison, pour faire de nouveaux stocks.
Elles sont 20 000 - 25000 en hiver.
En été, la population d'une ruche ?
Ça peut monter jusqu'à 60 000.
Elles vont refabriquer du miel
pour leur propre consommation.
Et puis elles vont en fabriquer
un peu plus.
Exactement, comme il y a vraiment
beaucoup de personnel à l'intérieur
de la ruche pendant la belle saison.
Il y a beaucoup d'ouvrières. Et quand la ruche sera pleine de pollen
et de nectar, et le surplus de miel, elles vont le monter dans la hausse.
Et nous,
on va récupérer ce surplus de miel.
On ne prendra jamais de miel à l'intérieur de la ruche.
C'est leur nourriture pour l'hiver
prochain.
Est-ce que nous prenons des risques à s'approcher d'une ruche
comme nous le faisons là ?
Oui, il y a quelques petites précautions
à prendre.
Vaut mieux éviter de passer devant
et de venir les déranger.
En revanche, dans la nature,
si on voit une abeille sur une fleur
en train de butiner,
il n'y a aucun risque.
Il n'y a aucun risque.
Elle est là pour amener de la nourriture
dans la ruche.
Alors là, c'est très beau aussi
parce qu'on voit les abeilles qui arrivent
chargées de pollen, les autres
qui repartent faire leurs courses.
On ne va pas les suivre
parce qu'elles vont très vite.
Et puis elles prennent des raccourcis
qu'on ne peut pas emprunter.
Et comme je sais
un peu ce qu'elles font derrière notre dos,
comment elles vont récolter le pollen
et le nectar.
On va aller dans l'atelier
pour voir comment elles travaillent
et je vais vous laisser préparer l'enfumoir
parce qu'ensuite, on va aller jeter un œil
sur ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de la ruche.
Une fois à l'extérieur,
les abeilles se dirigent
vers les plantes mellifères,
les plantes sur lesquelles
elles vont trouver le pollen et le nectar.
Ce précieux liquide est logé à la base
de la fleur.
Les abeilles se glissent entre les pétales,
puis l'aspirent et le stockent dans leur jabot.
Une petite poche qui se trouve à l'extrémité de l'œsophage.
Parallèlement, elles font des provisions de pollen.
Les fameuses petites pelotes jaunes
qu'elles transportent sous leurs pattes.
Puis elles vont visiter une autre fleur.
Et c'est durant ces visites
qu'elles déposent involontairement
les grains de pollen provenant
des étamines d'une fleur
sur le pistil d'une autre
et qu'elles participent
activement à la pollinisation des plantes.
Quand les soutes sont pleines,
après avoir visité
plusieurs dizaines de fleurs,
elles rentrent à la ruche.
Là, elles régurgitent le nectar qui, au passage,
a déjà commencé
à se transformer dans le jabot.
Mais attention, elles ne le transvasent
pas directement dans les alvéoles.
Mais dans le jabot,
d'autres abeilles, plus jeunes : les nourrices.
Qui vont à leur tour le régurgiter dans le jabot d'une autre abeille.
On appelle cet échange la trophallaxie.
Oui, je sais, c'est
un peu perturbant de savoir
que le miel que l'on consomme est d'abord passé de bouche en bouche.
Cela dit, cette étape est indispensable,
car c'est au contact d'enzymes présentes
dans l'appareil digestif des abeilles
que le nectar devient du miel.
Puis ce nectar est déposé dans les alvéoles.
Une autre catégorie d'abeilles prend ensuite le relais.
Elles battent des ailes
au dessus de ces alvéoles.
Le courant d'air permet de déshydrater le miel.
Une fois la bonne densité
atteinte, d'autres, ferment les alvéoles,
à l'aide d'un opercule de cire,
qu'elles fabriquent elles-mêmes.
Et si on allait vérifier tout ça ?
Allez, c'est reparti !
Bon alors cette fois, je me suis équipé
parce qu'on va vraiment les déranger.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez mis dans l'enfumoir ?
Alors nous, pour allumer l'enfumoir, on va utiliser des copeaux de bois
et on va utiliser aussi des granulés de luzerne
pour que l'enfumoir dure plus longtemps.
Ok, ce ne sont que des végétaux.
Exactement.
Il n'y a aucun produit chimique là dedans.
Ce n'est pas le genre de la maison,
mais on va quand même vous enfumer.
On va prévenir les abeilles
qu'il va se passer quelque chose.
On va couper la communication
à l'intérieur de la ruche.
Du coup, on simule un incendie.
Et comme elles sont un petit peu en panique,
elles vont se gaver de miel
et elles vont être toutes douces
pour ouvrir la ruche.
Quand on dit qu'elles coupent la communication,
c'est qu'elles communiquent à partir de phéromones.
Et donc cette fumée empêche
la diffusion des phéromones.
Exactement, c'est ça. C'est bien ça ?
Voilà.
En fait, ça ne les endort pas, comme on dit ?
Non, non !
Et là, on arrive sur ce qu'on
appelle la hausse.
C'est la partie de la ruche
qui est exploitée.
Oui, elles vont venir
stocker le surplus de miel, en fait.
On va aller voir en dessous. Oh là là,
Ah ! c'est merveilleux.
Vous avez la reine, là ?
Oui, ça y est !
On voit qu'elle est
un peu plus grosse que les autres,
surtout un peu plus longue.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait pendant ce temps, la reine là ?
En fait, elle va chercher un peu partout
où elle peut aller pondre.
Et en même temps
qu'elle se balade comme ça sur le cadre,
elle va déposer ses phéromones
pour indiquer à ses filles
qu'elle est bien là,
que tout va bien dans la ruche.
D'accord, donc, on voit une partie
un peu plus brune ici,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le couvain.
Voilà exactement.
La reine est venue pondre dans toutes ces alvéoles,
a déposé un œuf dans chaque alvéole
et ça va devenir une abeille, une ouvrière 21 jours plus tard.
Et donc, sur chaque cadre,
une partie est réservée
au couvain et une autre à la nourriture.
Là où c'est un peu plus jaune,
un peu plus clair, c'est soit du pollen,
soit du miel.
Là, on peut voir tout le pollen
et dans les coins et sur le haut,
on va retrouver les réserves de miel.
Par dessus, je mets une petite grille à reine,
ça va empêcher la reine de venir
pondre dans les alvéoles.
Dans cette partie là, on veut que du miel.
Donc la reine est concentrée,
elle, dans la ruche.
Et donc voilà la fameuse hausse.
Oui, on voit qu'il y a du miel.
On va le récupérer et on va l'emmener
à la miellerie, à l'atelier d'extraction
pour en extraire le miel.
Et nous voici dans la miellerie,
l'endroit où l'on va extraire le miel des cadres.
Alors Jérôme, la première des choses à faire pour récupérer le miel,
pour l'extraire,
c'est de retirer ces petits opercules là.
Voilà, pour extraire le miel, il faut absolument enlever l'opercule.
Sinon, il n'y a rien qui va sortir.
Et dès que je vais
l'enlever, l'opercule va tomber.
Et le miel...
Qu'est-ce-que vous utilisez ? C'est une drôle d'arme !
C'est un petit couteau chauffant
pour que ce soit plus facile à enlever, l'opercule.
D'accord.
Et oui, la chaleur fait fondre la cire.
Dès que j'enlève la cire, le miel va commencer à couler.
On va voir toutes les alvéoles qui sont remplies en dessous
Après, on n'a plus qu'à mettre le cadre dans l'extracteur.
Et maintenant,
c'est avec la force centrifuge que le miel
va être projeté contre la paroi.
Oui, on parle d'extracteur,
mais c'est une centrifugeuse.
Et comme on dit dans le jargon, ça tourne.
On voit les parois de la centrifugeuse
qui sont constellées de gouttes de miel  qui s'étale.
Parce qu'effectivement, sous l'effet
de la force centrifuge,
Le miel liquide est projeté le long de la paroi
et ensuite, il va s'écouler.
Regardez ce beau miel
qui s'accumule sur les parois.
Donc voilà, on voit que la plupart du
miel est sorti des alvéoles.
Ah oui, c'est vide !
Et qu'est-ce qu'on fait là du miel
qui se trouve au fond de l'extracteur ?
Donc là, on va ouvrir la vanne
Et c'est parti.
Que c'est beau !
Il est prêt à être consommé ? À peine là !
Pendant l'extraction,
il y a des petits morceaux de cire
qui vont partir un petit peu avec.
Là, le miel, on va le laisser couler,
le laisser décanter toute la nuit
pour que la cire remonte bien à la surface.
Et demain matin, on n'a plus qu'à enlever la cire à la surface
pour pouvoir le mettre en pot.
On n'a plus qu'à le filtrer une dernière fois
pour être sûr qu'il n'y ait plus de morceaux de cire.
Et il est prêt à être consommé.
Et ça, c'est du vrai miel.
Oh, j'ai envie de goûter moi aussi !
T'inquiète pas, je t'en ramène.
Oui, mais alors
si on ne s'approvisionne pas
directement chez le producteur,
comment savoir si c'est
un vrai ou un faux miel ?
C'est très difficile.
Pour cela, il faut des machines sophistiquées
qu'on ne trouve qu'en laboratoire.
Alors bien sûr,
il y a des contrôles inopinés,
mais on ne peut pas vérifier
tous les pots qui arrivent sur le marché.
Alors comment faire ?
Retour à l'atelier.
Je vais vous donner quelques astuces.
Merci Jérôme. Au revoir ! À bientôt ! Merci !
Il existe plusieurs
astuces pour s'approcher du vrai.
D'abord, le prix.
On l'a vu pour produire du miel,
il faut des abeilles, des machines,
un savoir-faire.
Tout cela a un coût et donc un prix.
Je vous donne une fourchette.
Une fourchette ?
Avec une cuillère, c'est plus facile quand même !
Mais non, une fourchette de prix !
Du miel à 5€ le kilo, c'est louche.
Attention, j'ai bien dit 5€ le kilogramme, pas le pot !
Pour un vrai miel,
il faut plutôt compter dans les 10 -15€ le kilogramme.
Ensuite, regardez bien les étiquettes.
La provenance d'un miel est une information capitale.
Dans quel pays a-t-il été récolté ?
À partir de quelle fleur ?
Attention, ce n'est pas parce qu'il
vient de l'étranger qu'il est mauvais.
Mais dans ce cas,
je vous conseille de choisir un miel
qui a une provenance unique
et clairement identifiée.
D'ailleurs, certains miels
ne peuvent venir que de l'étranger.
Car les fleurs dont ils sont issus
ne poussent pas sur notre territoire.
En fait,
il faut se méfier des mentions
trop vagues comme "assemblages de miels
issus de l'Union européenne
et hors Union européenne".
Les fleurs dont le miel est issu
doivent également être mentionnées.
Plus il y a d'informations précises
plus le produit est traçable,
plus vous pouvez remonter à sa source.
Tenez, par exemple.
Miel de châtaignier du Périgord.
On connaît la fleur et la région d'où il vient.
Récolté et extrait à froid par l'apiculteur.
On sait également comment il a été récolté.
Un détail peut vous alerter
sur l'authenticité du miel.
Si l'étiquette précise "à conserver
au réfrigérateur après ouverture",
ce n'est pas bon signe.
Le miel est imputrescible, il ne pourrit pas,
ne se détériore pas
s'il est correctement fermé.
Pas besoin de le conserver
au réfrigérateur.
Dernier petit conseil pratique. Le vrai miel contient très peu d'humidité.
On l'a vu, les abeilles font
tout pour l'en débarrasser.
Donc, si vous avez un doute
sur votre achat, faites ce petit test.
Étalez le miel sur une tartine ou sur un Sopalin.
S'il reste en surface et n'imbibe pas
le support, c'est plutôt bon signe.
Le problème, c'est
que vous ne pouvez faire cette expérience
qu'après l'avoir acheté.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
pour ne pas en perdre une miette,
ou plutôt une goutte. Abonnez-vous à la chaîne.
C'est juste en dessous.
Et si la vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez
pas non plus à laisser un pouce bleu.
Ça fait toujours plaisir.
Allez à très bientôt
les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux.
Et régalez-vous !